if there was ever a sign that the Trump
Russia scandal was getting even more
serious it is that Donald Trump is
personally lawyering up Donald Trump has
now personally retained a lawyer Marc
Casa Wits to represent him directly in
the various investigations that are
going on related to Russian interference
and/or collusion in the 2016 election
Casa wits has known Trump for decades
has represented Donald Trump in the past
the White House was asked about this
reported hire and had no comment who do
you call for this right I mean how many
attorneys are experienced in defending
presidents from allegations of colluding
with foreign non friendly nations to
seize the White House I get that the
point of hiring Marc caso is is that
he's worked with Trump for a long time
it's not like when you're charged with I
don't know
drinking and driving and there's
attorneys who have handled hundreds and
hundreds of drinking and driving cases
this is a very very niche area and I
think really Pat this is more about
Trump knows this guy and presumably
trust this guy rather than this guy's an
expert in this type of thing it's hard
to become an expert on this type of
thing unless you also worked with Nixon
and Gannett and I guess but I think just
the fact that Trump is lawyering up
doesn't necessarily mean he's guilty you
know if you're innocent you'd want a
lawyer
it tells us that the fireworks could
only just be beginning so the important
thing is that there is this office of
the White House Counsel when things
start getting difficult presidents will
go outside to get personal attorneys
Bill Clinton did this as Pat mentioned
Nixon Clinton Clinton was impeached as
you may recall not removed from office
as a result of that impeachment and he
had a personal lawyer as always with
Trump there is either a double standard
or a conflict of interest not far from
the story and that's the case here as
reported by Rachel Maddow last night
Donald Trump's lawyer I mean it's you
know where I'm going with the stat
Donald Trump's lawyer that he is
retaining to help him with the Trump
Russia scandal mark Kassovitz is himself
connected to Russia Mark Kassovitz
was recently named a lead attorney in a
federal civil lawsuit
against Burbank which is a bank that is
majority owned by none other than the
Russian government
he hired a lawyer who is connected to
Russia to defend him against allegations
potential allegations potentially
criminal allegations of collusion with
Russia and until a few hours ago it was
reported that a possible replacement for
FBI director James Comey would be Joe
Lieberman and initially they thought
there would be some bipartisan support
there because Lieberman was a longtime
Democrat of course ran with Al Gore in
2000 and that maybe he would get
Republican support as well because he
supported the Iraq war and he endorsed
John McCain in 2008 but if you get this
Joe Lieberman worked at the same law
firm as Trump's lawyer so there would be
a clear conflict of interest and I think
that was just a bridge too far can you
imagine if you've got Trump being
defended against within the context of
the FBI's Trump Russia investigation and
then you've got a guy from the exact
same law firm as his attorney at least
somewhat involved in that investigation
along with prosecutors special
prosecutor Robert Muller not going to
happen and I think we're back to the
drawing board Trump last week was saying
any day now I'm going to tell you who
the FBI the new FBI director is going to
be yeah now reportedly are they
completely back to the drawing board on
that what's not gonna be Texas Senator
John Cornyn and I gotta me not gonna be
Joe Lieberman so yeah they've hit the
reset button on that one yeah yet
another and this is a trend we've seen
with Trump just taking forever to hire
people that need to be hired for open
positions and this is at the highest
levels and also you know hundreds and
thousands of people at lower levels of
government just a very very strange
thing just the logistics of the White
House are just as bad as the optics of
the White House today's program is made
possible in part by taga dabbe the
hosting specialist taga dev offers a
range of affordable and flexible hosting
packages including dedicated virtual
private servers and cloud server options
as well as custom server solutions and
colocation services they're really proud
of their team of expert hosting
specialists who also happen to make up
their friendly support team and they do
give their customers full access to
their knowledge and service and with a
growing number of people
interested in moving their businesses
and projects to the cloud taga dab are
currently offering a 10 British Pound
free credit to all new customers signing
up to give you a chance to try the
service you can take advantage of this
offer by going to sign up CagA DAB comm
/ TDPS support our program by supporting
our sponsors